Trying is about a couple who
decide to
embark on parenthood and realize
that they can't.
So they look into other options.
I think I'm ready to talk about
adopting.
Yea!
Esther:
And they decide to go through
that process.
Which is a lot harder than I
think they realize.
Sandra:
You totally sure about this?
You gotta be careful with
adoption.
Mel, from the club got a rescue
dog, shat everywhere.
I don't know what I'm supposed
to do with that information.
♪♪
I play a social worker who's
helping a couple to try and
adopt.
I can get a little bit personal.
-Yea, no that's fine.
-Go for it.
How often would you say you
have sex?
Andy:
I was adopted as a young child.
You don't often hear about the
process and how difficult that
is.
Andy:
And I just think it's ripe for
a really fantastic series.
I'm so excited.
Part of the fun is gonna be
watching how these two people
respond to being judged on
whether you are a good enough
person to adopt a child.
We should make a list of the
flaws that we wanna iron out.
You drink too much.
You need to work on your anger.
Fine put it down.
♪♪
The having to grow up
and maybe realize
yourself as an adult and
what that means.
No!
Talk to your children!
They're not my children!
Haha.
I don't think I'm ever going to
feel like an adult.
♪♪
We're all trying to make sense
of it... Hahaha.
That's suggests an air of um,
calmness and dependability.
Yeah, I like that.
At the end of the day, it's
about what's missing
and it's about what we do to
fill that hole.
Crazy people don't know they're
crazy.
And yet here we are.
♪♪
I think we are gonna to be
amazing parents.
(Cork-pops)
♪♪